hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of this year sinfeld cup we said
that uh depending on how it all goes it
will be either yanipanoshi or alireza
furuja who will uh take it all lyresa
already won the entire grand chester now
it was only a matter of who will
actually win the sing-field cup and this
is a moment from the game and eppo had
against uh hans niemann in round nine
and this was the position uh the
critical one where nipple wielding the
white pieces could have captured and h6
created a past h pawn and this would
have been winning for him however he
didn't go for this he uh tried tried
something something else for example
after rook to a4 by niemann he didn't
capture the pawn he played a three and
uh very very quickly the position uh
unfolded into a draw f5 rook the c3
kinked to e7 and now rook to b8 again
not going after the pawn uh nipple said
that he just thought that his position
was completely winning uh that he could
capture this pawn whenever he wanted
but after rook to a6 now once the bishop
moves also the pawn will be protected
there is no good way to do this also
rook the b6 check is the threat of um
trading rooks and undoubling black
spawns so king c2 rook to b6 rook to a8
and now rook a6 again defending the pawn
uh there is no good way to
at uh to go after it if you now play
rook to h8 uh sorry if you go rook to h8
just bishop to d7 the rook from e6
nicely guards the h6 pawn so uh nepo was
very very unhappy about how he uh
handled this this game but okay still he
went into the playoff against alireza
firuja and now we are going to discuss
what happened in that game that is of
course a rapid game and uh
uh first game between the two of them
ended in a draw and basically this game
whoever wins it wins the entire scene
field cup uh so let's see how it went
alireza has the white pieces and he
opens with c4
going for the english
knight to f6 g3 and e5 we have bishop to
g2 and pawn to c6 preparing to strike in
the center with d5 and now you could
prevent this by going e4 but not knight
to f3 inviting nipple for the early e4
we have e4 knight to d4 and now pawn to
d5 so we already had this line but here
alireza will take a bit of a different
turn c captures queen captures and now
as the knight is attacked we had a game
where knight to see tonight the c3 was
played but here all it is it just
defends the knight with e3 uh we have
knight to a6 and now pawn to d3 of
course um now attacking the pinned pawn
uh bishop to b for check knight the c3
and now captures captures and knights
the c5 putting pressure on the d3 pawn
and usually d captures an e4 is played
here but uh here uh alireza plays c4 and
it is now a new move so already as of
move 11 we have a completely new game
so nipple goes back with the queen queen
e5 also the knight can't really move as
the rook on a1 would hang so d captures
on e4 knight c captures on e4 and here
are just castles we have pawn to c5 uh
chasing away the knight and now you have
to go back to b3 to defend the rogue you
could also maybe throw in a rook to e1
uh it is possible although you don't
really gain anything of course uh nipple
will not capture and allow the e file to
open up he's just gonna castle and then
you're gonna play knight to b3 so uh
it's uh it's all the same so knight to
b3 right away we have castles in the now
pawn to f3 kicking away the knight
knight to d6 and e4 and here we reach
the spectacular moment of the game uh
that uh well it is just amazing that uh
that the you know the events of the uh
of this uh tournament unfold in such a
way alireza is now threatening pawn to
f4 you chase away the queen and then
pawn the e5 that will win one of the
knights so of course nepo sees this and
he moves the queen he doesn't want to
have f4 to come with tempo
but uh the uh you know uh reality of the
matter is that it doesn't matter uh so
feel free to pause the video and to win
this game for alireza uh well i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the e5 move has to be played right away
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course pawn to
e5 it doesn't matter that f4
hasn't been played
the point is that if queen now captures
an e5 just bishop f4 nipple blunders the
knight here and there's nothing uh he
can do about this there's no good move
here if queen f5 just bishop captures or
even queen captures you are down a full
piece so nipple tried to complicate
things he played knight captures on c4
uh e captures on f6 queen captures and
now queen to d5 all it is that goes
after the c5 pawn so bishop to e6
defending the knight and queen captures
on c5 so and now nipple has a pawn for a
piece and that's not all that great
especially if you're playing against
alireza uh but uh there's nothing else
to do he can resign or he can maybe try
and hope for a miracle h6 with ponte f4
rook 8 d8 and now pawn to f5 chasing
away the bishop so he can capture the
knight so b6 here queen to c7 and rook
to c8 defending the the knight on c4 so
queen f4 and now bishop to d7 and now
just queen to d4 so this is how ali is
uh forces a queen trait as the bishop is
hanging if you play some like queen e7
queen to d8 those are all very very
passive moves the rook will just um
go
continue harassing the queen uh the the
there's no good way to play this so here
queen captures on d4 uh grabbing the
queen knight captures and now rook uh
after d8 uh still continuing the game
bishop to f4 and now bishop to a4
putting pressure on the knight stopping
rook to d1 so knight to f3
uh and now bishop to c2 attacking the f5
pawn we have g for defending it and
knight to b2 there is nothing nepo can
try here basically he's hoping for a
miracle 95 we have bush back to a4 and
now rook 8 to c1 alireza just forces
further trades as he is so much up in
material any trade is good for him
sorrow captures rook captures with pawn
to f6 and now knight to g6 we have
knight to d3 attacking the rook and rook
to c7 and he was in this position on
move 34 that yanni pognashi resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so as jan said very very sad uh end
to a very sad tournament first not
taking his chances against uh hans
niemann here where he could have just uh
captured the the pawn and it's basically
game over uh and against alireza just
blundering a piece like that not a
characteristic of a former 2800 player
and a former world chess championship
challenger uh but what do you what are
you gonna do
uh and in the current world championship
challenger uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it big
congratulations to alireza on not only
winning the sinkfield cup but also the
entire grand chester if you guys are
interested these are the final standings
of the of the grand chester you can see
that uh
let me just
uh all right let's just make that a
little bit smaller
so you can see the bonuses as well uh so
all it is that wins the entire grand
chester winning uh a hundred and seventy
two thousand dollars plus a one hundred
thousand dollar bonus wesley so in
second place with 140 000 plus fifty
thousand dollar bonus and maxine vashir
lagrav uh in third place also a hundred
and forty thousand dollars with twenty
five thousand dollars bonus and so on
fabi in fourth level in fifth janipan
machine sixth uh seven is linear
dominguez
uh in eight and nine is erica rapport so
truly truly incredible stuff
uh there you have it big congratulations
to alireza once again and yeah it's
interesting that alirezan also won the
saint louis rapid and blitz event before
going into this so he just really really
played incredible chess and he just uh
obliterated everyone
so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it and this short coverage of
the of the singfield cup we're going to
cover some other events that took place
while this was happening and there are
some fun games that happened like i
don't know if you've seen the
uh the the the famous castles fork uh
it's incredible that such a thing
happened in in a game between two grand
masters but i i will probably cover that
game as well uh so yeah uh once again
really hope you enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank ravishing reptiles youtube
another casual coder david kimura john
gear law office and abdul rahman al-sawd
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh to check
out on whatever else is happening in the
chess world and on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and i will keep you informed if
we know anything more about the whole
magnus situation uh see you soon